any pyramid scheme whether it's  freemasonry or  you know multi-level marketing or  scientology or whatever  they have a few people at the top  who know what's up and who have a plan  that plan can relate to genocide  depopulation  different kinds of occultist religious  beliefs spiritual  you know sort of orientation whatever  they have a plan  and nobody beneath the tip  of that pyramidal space knows what the  hell is going on and that's by design  right so as you get lower and lower down  the rungs and you have people like me in  medical school just trying to be a good  girl  right at the bottom implementing uh and  instituting  many elements of the agenda you know  in disguise